[MUSIC PLAYING]
They're are arrows more
dangerous than that one?
Marvel Studios' Hawkeye
is always on target, thanks
to VFX supervisor, Greg Steele.
Hey, Greg.
Hey, Lorraine.
How are you?
Thanks for having me today.
Oh, I am doing excellent.
But, you know, much
like Kate, I am
dying to know more about
all of the different trick
arrows in Hawkeye's arsenal.
So how did you and
the production team
work together to
create these arrows?
The props department
is really involved
in coming up with a lot of
these designs, which is great.
I mean, the work they
did in building these,
they're like little
pieces of artwork
in terms of the complexity
and the design aesthetic.
It's really great.
And it all lives within
the realm of what's
come before in the other films.
And the arrows that the
characters were holding
were not real, but
they were based
on things the prop
department had put together.
Like the tip of
the PYM arrow had
a blue illumination and the
word, you could read it.
We scan pretty much everything
we do when we're on the film,
so we'll scan all the locations
and the actors and the props
also.
You've got the
geometry, which is
the foundational shape of it.
And then you go in and you
try to replicate the feeling
of the surface and quality.
So the shininess,
how beat up it is,
where there's little
lights that could turn on,
things like that.
And then you age it and
try and make it look
like it kind of belongs
in the real world
versus being totally synthetic.
It's definitely a lot
of work, but it's so worth
it when you see it in
scenes like the epic
car chase in episode three.
What are some of the different
arrows we see in that scene
and how did you
bring them to life?
So, the putty arrow is
one of the first arrows
that Kate shoots
during the car chase.
Once the arrow hits,
it expands and creates
this almost like expansion
foam-type quality.
So to create
something like that,
we ended up just shooting the
plate of the truck driving.
And then in post-production,
we did effects simulations
on the glass.
So they reference material that
we had found of expansion foam
and some slimes and things
like that that everyone liked.
And then, basically, put it
all together and just kind of
gave a really kind
of goopy messy look.
The explosive arrow
was one that was
launched by Kate at the
beginning of the sequence.
It jams into the bumper
of a van and causes
a giant explosion as
it flips end-over-end,
kind of rolling
towards them almost.
The special effects
team and the stunts team
rigged up two different
events of a real van.
One was to get it
rolling so it could
be kind of chasing
along after the car,
and one to get it
going initially.
And then it was up to us in
visual effects to kind of help
augment that a little bit,
clean up the stunt rigging.
We added some additional fire
and some other explosions
to kind of just make it all
tie together amongst the shots.
The suction cup
arrow is what appears
to be a very benign suction
cup arrow at the beginning
of the sequence, which ends
up actually saving them
at the end as Clint suction
cup onto a subway car
as it's speeding below
on the Manhattan bridge.
Get the plunger arrow on it.
So the Octo-grabber
arrow is an arrow
device that shoots
cables out from
itself and then pulls back in.
Kate, basically, fires the arrow
into the front of the truck
that Cozi's driving.
It spools out all these cables
inside the Christmas lot,
which they're driving through,
and pulls all the Christmas
trees causing them to
smash all over the vehicle
and kind of make them drive
out of control and crash.
We shot all the plates without
Christmas trees in the lot.
So we left space in a Christmas
tree lot dressed with trees
that the cars could
kind of drive-through
and the stuntman
can kind of do all
the action they needed to do.
For most of the shots, we were
putting all these computer
generated trees that were
built based on some reference
that we had.
There's some that
are wrapped in,
encased in kind of
a wrapping, and some
just kind of furled out.
They built those and
then they rigged them up
so they could simulate such
that if you smashed a tree
into something, all the branches
and all the pine needles
would do what
they're supposed to.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Merry Christmas.
So the acid arrow is utilized
when Kate and Clint are
speeding towards an
intersection with cross traffic
and they need to, basically,
create a hole in the traffic
so they can sneak
through it with the guys
chasing after them.
So Clint hands Kate
two acid arrows
and she's instructed to shoot
them at the traffic lights.
They fly through the air and
they hit a CG traffic light
pole, it burns away, and they
kind of fall to the ground
simmering and smoldering.
The PIM arrow, there's
two forms PIM arrows.
There's the ones that
shrink and then there's
the ones that grow much larger.
At the end of the
sequence, they're trapped,
the car has been
smashed, and Clint
tells Kate to take
a regular arrow
and shoot it up in the sky.
We see that Clint has
got a blue PIM arrow.
And he fires at it as
the arrow is coming down
and it scales up and chops
the truck basically in half.
It was something
that we had played
around with in terms
of how the arrow
could go through the truck.
I believe it was Kevin
who had the idea.
He said, no, no,
shoot it straight up
and then have it
come straight down
and chop the truck in half.
And it ended up actually
working out really well.
Everything in that
environment is all CG.
So the bridge, the environment
of New York, and all that
was all basically replicated.
It's a real synergistic
thing between stunts
and special effects
and visual effects.
That's one of the fun
things about the job
is actually being able to work
with all the different teams
to put this together.
Well, it takes a village.
And just when we think
we've seen it all,
you pull out all of the
stops for that final battle
in the finale.
Now, what are some of the
arrows that you bring back
and some of the new arrows that
you introduced for this scene?
So the luminous
arrow was, I think,
the first arrow that Kate
shoots inside the ice rink.
And that's basically
a huge blinding light
just to try to kind
of blind them so they
can kind of get some cover.
I'd say 95% of the shots were
shot in Atlanta on a backlot.
For us, it was taking all
the footage that we had shot
and just augmenting what
was a one story building
and turn it into a
big 65 floor high
rise skyscraper in New York.
The electromagnetic
arrow is something
that's used at the beginning
of the ice rink fight.
The big question during prep was
when we were kind of designing
this was why don't all the
bad guys just shoot them
once they're down
inside the rink?
So we came up with
this gag of Clint
shooting an electromagnetic
arrow at the flagpole,
and it basically creates this
electro net all around the ice
rink and it pulls all of
the metal-based weaponry
out of the bad
guys' hands and kind
of sticks it to the flagpoles.
In post, we put in the
electro aspect of it
with the lightning bolts
and electricity and things
like that.
So the acid arrow comes back
actually in the final battle.
It's before Clint lets Kate
use all the good trick arrows
when they get down to the ice.
She's basically
up in FAO Schwarz,
and Clint is stuck in
a tree at this point.
So she, basically, fires
it at the trunk of the tree
and cause the weight of the
tree to actually fall over.
Clint goes flying,
everything is a hot mess
down on the ice rink.
Special effects built
us a special tree trunk
that we could actually crack.
Our vendor team
put in a the acid
that was eating away
at it, causing bubbles
and smoke coming off it.
And then the tree itself
as that falls just
has a massive amount of
stimulation going on.
Kate fires the needle
arrow towards a place
where a bunch of tracksuit
mafia are standing.
So she fires it,
it hits the ice,
and winds up small
needles, like a porcupine,
go flying out of this thing and
just stabbing into all the guys
around it, just kind of
causing mayhem, basically,
at the beginning of the fight.
The actual final effect was
designed during post-vis
as we were doing it.
We had the actual plates and
we just basically implemented
a CG version of that
shooting until all
the actors who
were miming getting
hit by the different needles.
The tranq arrow is an arrow that
is a delivery system yet again.
So the main arrow goes
into a guy's shoulder,
so it's just a bunch of
little hypodermic needles
that shoot into the
different characters.
But the performances, again,
for something like that
is really what sell it.
The airbag, again, is one
of those great combinations
between stunts and visual
effects and second unit teams.
It was something the stunts
team came up with in their stunt
biz about this concept of a cool
air-bag that could kind of go
under the characters
and grow huge and send
them flying into the air.
To actually implement
that, the stunt team set up
a bunch of cranes and they
could kind of actually
pull the characters
up into the air.
So we were able to
actually use real people
doing the stunts versus
having to go to a digit double
all the time.
The sonic concussion arrow is an
arrow that first gets revealed
in episode 4, and
that's basically
an arrow that
creates a large kind
of a three-beat
concussive sonic blast.
So, again, we used similar
techniques to what we had done,
creating these
concentric compressed air
simulations to kind
of just make it feel
very powerful and concussive.
The giant explosion
arrow that kind of
happens at the end of
the ice rink sequence
is very similar to the one
that took out the van earlier.
But for the most part,
the lighting teams created
some interactive light for us.
The stunt team rigged
up some performers
to come flying through the
air, get up off the ground,
and get pulled by these cables
and come flying forward.
Visual effects-wise, we ended
up adding all the explosion
and the debris that would fly.
The splitting of
the regular arrow.
So Clint's down to two
arrows with three bad guys
coming at him.
So what he does is he fires
one and then quickly fires
another one with
greater force, causing
that second arrow to cut
through the first arrow,
splitting it in half.
So he basically
creates three arrows.
We created all the camera
movement in computer graphics.
We had our virtual
set so we could
put them anywhere and just kind
of move the camera through it.
So we chased along behind
the arrow in animation
and split it, added
effect simulations,
and things like that
to make it very clear
that it's a wooden arrow.
The PIM arrow comes back
again in the ice rink fight,
but this time
instead of actually
making something gigantic, it's
used to shrink down something.
And there's several
tracksuit mafia
that are careening a big
truck into the ice rink
to try to kind of smash Kate and
Clint as a last ditch effort.
And as it's coming
towards them, Kate
pulls out a PIM shrinking
arrow and fires it at the van,
shrinking it down.
We shot as much as we could
with the actors in the frame,
but a lot of their
shots ended up just
being fully computer-generated
with the trucks barreling
across the Plaza because we
had built our CG environment,
we could just drive our
CG trucks through it.
We had computer
generated people standing
down there as the truck
hurtles towards them.
So after that moment, Kate
turns to Clint and says,
well, I wasn't really expecting
it to end that way-type thing.
This kind of odd moment where
an owl comes in and takes
that little truck away.
Well, there goes that.
Now, was that a real owl
or was it something that you
had to create in post with CGI?
It was a CG owl.
It was Kevin's idea to
have the owl in the tree.
You obviously read about the
owl that was in the Rockefeller
tree that year.
And they called it Rocky.
So that's what we've
called our little owl.
And she's really small,
she's only about yay big,
and she looks just
like the real one.
And it was a very specific type,
so we matched pretty much all
the feathering and
everything to make it
look as authentic as possible.
But she's very adorable.
[LAUGHTER]
That she is.
And now looking back
at this entire series,
what was your favorite
part of working on it?
I mean, the content
itself is amazing.
One of the original Avengers,
his storyline, and handing
the mantle over to Kate Bishop.
It's a really cool
storyline that we're all
very excited to be working on.
Everyone's kind of at their
A-game on these projects.
And it's really neat
to be able to kind
of collaborate with them.
That's probably one
of my favorite parts
of the whole process.
Teamwork makes the dream work.
Thank you so much, Greg.
And, of course, go check
out all of those trick
arrows in Marvel
Studios' Hawkeye,
now streaming all episodes
only on Disney Plus.